this was the equation we looked at in
the previous video
x plus 3 equals 10.
i have left some space here
intentionally
there are two ways in which we can solve
an equation
the phrase solving an equation means
finding the value of the variable that
satisfies the equation
by satisfies i mean a value of the
variable that equates the hand side and
the right hand side
so our aim in linear equations is mainly
to find the value of this variable x
the first method is the inverse
operations method
before you understand this method we
need to understand a simple concept
whatever we do to the left hand side we
do the same to the right hand side
let us choose a random number say five
assume we add this number to the left
hand side
for the equation to hold true we have to
add the same number to the right hand
side
similarly if we subtract 5 from the left
hand side we have to subtract the same
number from the right hand side
if we multiply the left hand side by the
number
we have to multiply the right hand side
by the same number
but remember we have to multiply the
entire side but putting these brackets
here it means that we multiplied the
entire left hand side by five
and if we divide the left hand side by
the number we also divide the right hand
side by the same number note that 5 was
a random number
now you should be wondering how this
concept helps us solve an equation
this concept is the crux of the inverse
operations method
just remember this concept
we move to a new page to solve a new
linear equation
say we want to solve the equation 2x
plus 5 equals 13.
how do we use the inverse method to
solve this equation
remember when we have to solve such
equations our aim should be to keep only
the variable on the left hand side
we have to eliminate everything else
so our first task should be to eliminate
five
so we will have to subtract five from
the left hand side but we just learnt a
concept that said if we subtract a
number from the left hand side we have
to subtract the same number from the
right hand side hence we subtract five
from both sides
we get two x plus five minus five equal
to thirteen minus five
we subtracted five from both sides 5
cancels out on the left hand side and
the right hand side equals 8.
hence our equation reduces to 2x equals
8.
now to have just the variable on the
left hand side we have to eliminate its
coefficient which is two
so we can just divide the left hand side
by two
and if we divide the left hand side by
two we have to divide the right hand
side also by two
so we divide both sides by two
we get two x by two equals eight by two
two cancels out on the left hand side
and eight by two equals four
hence we get x equal to 4.
this tells us that if you put 4 in place
of x here you will get a 13.
let's review this method quickly
our aim was to have only the variable on
the left hand side
so we first eliminated 5 by subtracting
5 from both sides
and then we eliminated 2 by dividing
both sides by 2 which gave us the value
of x as 4. the last step after solving
the equation should be to check our
answer
so on the left hand side we substitute
the value of x and see if it equals the
right hand side
the left hand side is 2x plus five
substituting four in place of x we get
two multiplied by four plus five
that equals eight plus five which is
thirteen the same as the right hand side
so we say that our value of x is correct